Microsoft wants to empower developers to
build smarter apps using artificial
intelligence and revolutionize how we
experience technology but most
developers who are not part of a large
well resourced institution do not have
the expertise data or time to add this
capability Microsoft is making available
artificial intelligence based vision
speech and language AP is developed from
years of research these technologies are
used in many Microsoft products with as
little as three lines of code developers
will be able to build apps capable of
things like recognizing the emotion on a
face and a photograph to understanding
words and meaning in speech building
smarter apps has never been easier get
started for free at project Oxford AI